[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
berichte und claus kleber
guten abend den kabul haben die usa das
letzte kapitel ihres abzugs begonnen
afghanische helfer praktisch keine
chance mehr auf eine militärmaschine zu
kommen die militärs sind sich mit sich
selbst beschäftigt mit rückzug im
gefährlichsten manöver weil die abwehr
mit jedem schritt raus schwächer wird
präsident biden gibt offen zu dass er
jeden moment einen neuen anschlag
erwartet menschen in washington die
nerven so gespannt sind wie dann erst
bei denen die jetzt zurück bleiben den
taliban ausgeliefert sonst ist da
niemand mehr ein tödlicher stromschlag
der usa heute gegen zwei es anführer
kann daran gewiss nichts ändern wenn
jemand über die vielen jahre in
washington brüssel berlin albträume über
den ausgang dieses krieges hatte dann
müssen die etwa so ausgesehen haben wie
heute katrin eigendorf berichtet die
lage am hamid karzai flughafen ist
gefährlicher denn je in seltener
einigkeit warnen us soldaten und taliban
davor sich den eingängen zu nähern doch
es schreckt sie nicht menschen die auch
heute noch versuchen auf einen der
letzten evakuierungsflüge zu kommen die
usa haben mit ihrem abzug begonnen
mehrere tausend soldaten müssen noch
zurückgebracht werden auf den letzten
fliegern wird kaum noch platz sein für
zivilisten am dienstag soll alles vorbei
sein die angst vor neuen anschlägen ist
in den straßen kabuls spürbar sicherheit
gibt es nicht mehr seitdem die taliban
die macht übernommen haben doch die
neuen machthaber machen die usa dafür
verantwortlich dass ein
selbstmordattentäter des afghanischen
ablegers des islamischen staates einen
anschlag verüben konnte in einem
gespräch mit dem zdf stellt es ihr
sprecher so dar
die explosion fand statt in dem bereich
für den die amerikaner verantwortlich
waren wir hatten mit ihnen eine grenze
vereinbart die unsere soldaten nicht
betreten durften so wie sie keine
erlaubnis hatten unsere seite zu
betreten
auch für den tagelangen ansturm auf den
flughafen bei dem bereits vor dem
anschlag mehr als 20 menschen zu tode
kamen machen die taliban die usa und
ihre verbündeten verantwortlich dass
afghanen vor ihrem terror fliehen weiß
der sprecher zurück
in jedem dritte welt land die würde eine
solche gedrängte situation entstehen
wenn man erklären würde man nimmt 20.000
menschen mitten nach europa oder in die
usa
dass menschen ein besseres und gutes
leben in anderen ländern haben wollen
ist doch ein menschliches anlegen und
doch das ist kabul am tag zwei nach dem
anschlag angehörige der opfer warten vor
der notaufnahme des krankenhauses auf
ein lebenszeichen ihrer angehörigen
viele bringen drinnen noch um ihr leben
es gibt tausende menschen die wie ich
vor den toren der krankenhäuser um den
flughafen herum auf nachricht warten
leute deren leben zerstört wurde und die
alles verloren haben
zerstörte leben und ein land in dem so
viele menschen jetzt alles hinter sich
lassen auf der flucht vor jenen die eine
neue ordnung preisen doch in ihrem
islamischen emirat afghanistan ist in
diesen tagen nichts mehr in ordnung
unsere reporterin katrin eigendorf ist
auf dem weg von taschkent nach katar
gerade in istanbul katrin wie weit ist
es her mit ordnung und kontrolle unter
den taliban
wie sich die lage im moment darstellt
scheint dieses land immer mehr im chaos
zu versinken
das spielt sich auf verschiedenen ebenen
ab einmal haben die taliban nicht in
allen bereichen des landes die kontrolle
isd formiert sich ja zum beispiel im
pandschir tal eine starke
widerstandsbewegung die auch mit
waffengewalt gegen die taliban vorgehen
will dann das größte problem der ableger
des islamischen staates in afghanistan
der sich immer mehr zu einem
sammelbecken auch für die entwickelt die
nicht sagen wir mal mit der eher
diplomatischen linie der doha taliban
einverstanden sind die im prinzip ja
mehr gewalt anwenden wollen sich stärker
durchsetzen wollen das wird zu einem
problem wie der amerikanische präsident
joe biden angekündigt hat rechnet man ja
damit das ist weiterer anschläge auch
auf den flughafen in kabul geben wird
vermutlich schon in den nächsten 24 bis
36 stunden
die usa behalten sich ja auch vor
weitere drohnen anschläge zu verüben
gegen die terroristen also das ist keine
gute lage von stabilität oder davon dass
die taliban in irgendeiner form das land
im griff hätten kann keine rede sein und
da ist die versorgung der menschen noch
gar nicht mit im blick dankeschön
kathrin
zurück nach deutschland pandemie
hochwasserkatastrophe dann die
nachrichten vom chaos in afghanistan die
desaster scheinen sich derzeit zu
überstürzen bedrückende zeiten den
nachrichtenredaktionen wie im wahren
leben heute hat sich deutschland in
aachen mal zeit genommen für die opfer
der flut nicht um abzulenken um in sich
zu gehen dort bewerber berichtet
im aachener dom kommt an diesem morgen
die verzweiflung ganz nah
betroffene helfer politik vertreter der
kirchen sie alle hörenden absam ein
pastor aus den flutgebieten hatting
beschrieben
[Musik]
der bach den ich von kind an liebte sein
plätscherndes rauschen war wie musik zum
tod bringenden ungeheuer wurde er seine
gefräßigen fluten verschlagen ohne
erbarmen alles wurde mir genommen alles
weggespült das was ich mein leben nannte
ihm blieb nur die kerze einzige
lichtquelle in der flut sein pfarrhaus
in schleiden stand unter wasser
erinnerungen in einer stunde die sie in
trauer vereint sie gedenken derer die
nun fehlen und versuchen zu verarbeiten
was sie erlebt haben
die verluste werden von tag zu tag
deutlicher
neu hinzugekommen sind ängste die angst
vor dem versinken in den fluten
und dann die angst so vieler betroffener
die angst vor dem vergessenwerden
wie geht s weiter fragen sie auch heute
der menschengemachte klimawandel sei bei
uns angekommen stellte ratsvorsitzende
der evangelischen kirche in deutschland
fest vielleicht werden wir in 20 jahren
auf diese tage
zurückschauen und sagen
die dramatik dessen was damals passiert
ist die abgründe anleihe
haben unser land zum nachdenken gebracht
es ist eine hoffnung hoffnung macht auch
die große hilfsbereitschaft in der
katastrophe solidarität werde es weiter
geben sagt der bundespräsident
wir wissen dass sie uns brauchen
für lange zeit
und wir stehen an ihrer seite als
bundespräsident möchte ich ihnen
versichern
sie sind nicht allein
wir hören sie
wir vergessen sie nicht
gut sei noch lange nicht
heute gab es im raum für trauer und
trost in der gemeinsamkeit
nachrichten nun mit kaiser berichtet da
schauen wir auf die korona pandemie
bisher gab es wenige daten zu der frage
wie sich die delta variante auf das
risiko auswirkt schwer an co mit 19 zu
erkranken nun zeigt eine studie der
universität cambridge dass die mutation
doppelt so häufig zu einer
klinikeinweisung führt wie die alpha
variante mehr als 98 prozent der
beobachteten kugelt 19 erkrankten waren
nicht vollständig geimpft was die
wissenschaftler als bestätigung dafür
werten dass die impfstoffe sehr gut
wirken trotzdem flacht in deutschland
die im kurve immer weiter ab 60,1
prozent der bevölkerung haben sich die
zweite dosis inzwischen abgeholt zu
wenige für eine herdenimmunität auf der
anderen seite wird die inzidenz kurve
steil der aktuelle wert liegt bei
72,1 das robert koch institut meldete
außerdem zehn 1303 neue corona fälle
innerhalb von 24 stunden das sind 2211
mehr als vor einer woche außerdem kamen
binnen eines tages 22 todesfälle dazu
gegen die korona maßnahmen sind in
berlin mehrere tausend menschen auf die
straße gegangen trotz
demonstrationsverboten in mehreren
gruppen zogen sie durch verschiedene
stadtteile
als einige demonstranten versuchten eine
sperre zu durchbrechen setzte die
polizei pfefferspray ein sie war mit
2000 beamten im einsatz
die behörden hatten die proteste mit der
begründung verboten dass die teilnehmer
bewusst gegen die hygiene regeln
verstoßen wollten
der tarifstreit bei der deutschen bahn
spitzt sich auch rhetorisch immer weiter
zu so wirft konzernchef lutz den
gdl-vorsitzenden weselsky eine bewusste
spaltung der belegschaft vor wie
weselsky agiere und vor allem rede sei
absolutes gift für die
zusammengehörigkeit der eisenbahner
familie sagte lutz dem redaktions
netzwerk deutschland die
lokführergewerkschaft hat mich sehr mit
zwei streiks druck auf die verhandlungen
gemacht kritisierte der gdl gehe es
dabei weniger um tarifkonditionen als um
ihren einfluss selbst hatte mittwoch
weitere streiks in aussicht gestellt
aus den aktuellen corona zahlen
infektionen und impfungen zieht hamburg
jetzt eigene konsequenzen
es passiert nämlich gerade das was ihre
logen seit monaten ankündigen wer sich
nicht impfen lässt wird corona bekommen
wie schlimm das dann ausgeht liegt am
einzelfall so einfach ist das hamburger
zahlen spiegeln es bei menschen die
geimpft sind liegt die sieben tage
instituts bei
3,5 mit fast immer schwachen verlauf bei
ungeimpften sind es nicht 3,5 sondern 78
mit dem bekannten hohen anteil schwerer
verläufe deshalb setzt hamburg jetzt
entschieden auf impfung gewährt
geimpften und genesenen vorteile im
alltag die ein test ihnen nicht bringt
martin lesen berichtet
vor der party kommt die bürokratie heute
morgen meldet stefan fehrenbach seine
bar für das 2g modell im behörden portal
an bei ihm haben dann am montag nun auch
geimpfte und genesene zutritt der
vorteil keine abstands pflicht kann die
sperrstunde mehr gäste mehr umsatz das
ist für mich gut dass es für den staat
gut weil dann kann ich endlich wieder
steuern zahlen und kann dann auch wieder
meine leute aus der kurzarbeit holen bin
nicht mehr selber auf hartz iv
angewiesen
andere sind schneller mit countdown und
konfetti wird in der wunderbar auf st
pauli schon punkt mitternacht auf das 2g
modell umgestellt die voraussetzungen
entsprechende hinweisschilder
zugangskontrollen und auch alle
mitarbeiter müssen geimpft oder gewesen
sein
18 waren wieder andere lehnen die 2g
optionen ab wie dieses fitnessstudio
hier dürfen auch jene weiter trainieren
die nur einen test vorweisen
für mich ist es auch ein indirekter
impfzwang und ich will jetzt nicht
anfangen ich auf irgendeine politische
diskussion zu geben ich freue mich dass
ich all meinen mitgliedern weiterhin das
training ermöglichen kann den vorwurf
eine eigentlich notwendige
grundsatzentscheidung der politik auf
die betriebe abzuwälzen und eine
impfpflicht durch die hintertür
einzuführen was der politisch
verantwortliche zurück das als pflicht
durch die hintertür zu bezeichnen das
halte ich für wirklich sehr gewagt so
können wir der gleichen logik auch sagen
es gibt eine führerscheinpflicht in
deutschland
weil man ja ohne führerschein darf man
nicht auto fahren man dann bestimmte
berufe nicht ergreifen aber es ist
ebenso wie aufgeheizt die diskussion um
erleichterungen für geimpfte und
genesene ist bekommt auch barbetreiber
fehrenbach zu spüren seit er verkündet
hat am zweig modell teilzunehmen erhält
der wüste beschimpfungen meist anonym
per mail ich wurde als nazi beschimpft
als faschist dann
wünschte man mir aber auch auf gleich
zweimal später dass ich mit meinen
antifaschisten glücklich fertigen werden
soll also ich bin bewegt mich zwischen
antifaschist faschist und genau
unterstützer eines apartheidsystems
gegen so viel wut und hass ist tanzen
mit mund nasenschutz das eindeutig
kleinere übel
umgestürzte bäume stromausfälle über
kuba hat wirbelsturm aila schon gewütet
nun bewegt er sich auf die us golfküste
zu und wird dabei immer stärker vor
allem im bundesstaat lousiana wussten
sich die einwohner für den hurrikan der
laut behörden extrem gefährlich wird aus
dem besonders gefährdeten new orleans
fliehen tausende doch es bleibt wohl
wenig zeit haider soll bereits morgen
ankommen und damit auf den tag genau 16
jahre nach hurrikan katrina
in deutschland ist es morgens war
ungemütlich aber nach aktuellem stand
zumindest im normalen rahmen die meisten
schauer und gewitter gibt es im osten
und süden an der nordsee ist es etwas
freundlicher
bei nördlichem wind steigen die
temperaturen auf 15 bis 21 grad an den
alpen auf 12 auch die neue woche startet
mit regen und gewinn und es bleibt auch
ziemlich kühl am dienstag wird es im
westen ab mittwoch auch im osten
freundlicher und dann ganz langsam auch
etwas er macht
wie immer samstags gibt es frische
lottozahlen wie immer ohne gewähr 11 18
24 25 41 46 superzahl 7 weitere
gewinnzahlen unter zdf.de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 6 na denn wir wünschen
ihnen noch einen angenehmen abend jetzt
beim sportstudio und dann einen schönen
sonntag bis 9
[Musik]